do you have a tattoo I do not have a
touch if you had to get one what would
you get
probably the cast of Gilligan's I just
to throw people off yeah yeah I would
how big standing in a line yeah covered
the whole chest are they on a little
island you know what I will say this we
have a writer on the shows very talented
writer who has tons and tons of tattoos
and he's always getting more of them and
I had this thought recently which is at
the end of the day you're just
entertaining the coroner like the
coroner is like all right what are we
doing today now this is many years from
now I hope this is someone I really care
about but they pull back the sheet and
oh hey look and it's like a magazine
yeah and instead of before they cut the
chest open and whatever they do you're
assuming they die of an unsolved mystery
most people most most the writers on my
show will die under somewhat sordid
circumstances but you know what I mean
while they're investigating the
autoerotic asphyxiation no no or the
drowning in molasses you know they're
going to have something to look at and
go oh look there's our 2d2 holding a
corona oh you know yeah that's an actual
real tattoo by the way the brighter has
no no no the writer he would get it if
he had thought of it but we did our tour
back in 2000 our 2010 tour a guy working
on my crew and hey color and I finally
got my dream tattoo check it out it was
r2d2 holding a Corona holding with a
little robot Owen with the little arm
that goes lays out the little arm that
comes out and goes move and rotates and
mysteriously solves every problem in the
script well we'd love to get a
commentary on the Star Wars problems out
of this just you know take it easy it's
a sensitive time right wow I've never
seen a beard sweat all right well anyway
let's stay on topic here before you get
on yours Star Trek wormhole okay same
thing now watch the comments it's lost
half your listeners so please well the
half the world's Star Trek had you know
I'd like to say that people may the
force be with you and prosper
you mix those two up you know yeah live
long and prosper
sona's look at me like she doesn't
understand no I know I don't know so
anyway don't want me to laugh yeah
look when I look at you and I hold up my
left thumb that usually means laughs
anyway I wonder how the woman is who has
the Conan on her butt cheek has she been
okay with that decision you think she's
had it removed or has she had the tattoo
altered to be another celebrity who's
probably worn better over time
slight adjustments yeah you just accept
slight adjustments to my face would make
a brad pitt tattoo mmm oh when I mean
slight I mean a complete removal and
regaining of Brad Pitt